they're coming to get you barbara
the zombie without remorse and pity
driven by hunger and damn near
impossible to put down permanently there
have been times since their introduction
into movies in the 1930s where it felt
like we'd never see a zombie movie ever
again then there are eras of the
opposite where you couldn't stick your
arm out in a multiplex without a
shambling ghoul nearby ready to chomp
and since we've been in feast mode over
the last decade plus we're taking a big
bite with our guide to some of the best
zombie movies you need to watch
[Music]
while zombie movies have been around for
more than 80 years it's commonly
accepted that the sub genre as we know
it today didn't rise until 1968 when
george a romero unleashed knight of the
living dead this independent film
enthralled audiences with its mysterious
plot shocking gore progressive casting
and social commentary oh and there's
also the unforgettable hordes of the
gaunt hungry undead romero was crowned
the godfather of zombies and he went on
to make five more dead movies say hello
to your aunt alicia
say hello and alicia
hello and alicia
hello
[Music]
now despite romero's efforts it would
still be a long shuffle into the early
2000s before zombies would break out of
the horror niche and crawl all over pop
culture the success of the resident evil
video games revealed an audience
appetite hitherto untapped inspiring a
gushing font of zombie movies released
between 2000 and 2005. now we got to see
the true versatility of the zombie movie
there was the loving spoofery of shaun
of the dead gritty filmmaking with 28
days later the micro budget one cut of
the dead and zombies even found their
way into found footage with wreck so
with all of that it is time to use your
brains and dig deep as we count down the
best zombie movies ever made
[Music]
number 10 the return of the living dead
when four man frank shows new employee
freddie a secret military experiment in
a supply warehouse the two klutz's
accidentally release a gas that
re-animates corpses into flesh-eating
zombies as the epidemic spreads
throughout louisville kentucky and the
creatures satisfy their hunger in gory
and outlandish ways frank and freddie
fight to survive with the help of their
boss and a mysterious mortician starring
clue gulliger james caron tom matthews
and directed by dan o'bannon critics say
a punk take on the zombie genre the
return of the living dead injects a
healthy dose of 80 silliness to the
flesh consuming
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
ready
[Applause]
number nine dead
alive overprotective mother vera
cosgrove spying on her grandson lionel
as he visits the zoo with the lovely
paquita is accidentally bitten by the
fearsome sumatran rap monkey when the
bite turns his beloved mother into a
zombie lionel tries to keep her locked
safely in the basement but her repeated
escapes turn most of the neighbors into
the walking dead who then crash a high
society party thrown by lionel's borish
uncle les starring timothy bomb diana
pena alved elizabeth moody and directed
by peter jackson critics say the
delightfully gonzo tale of a love struck
teen and his zombified mother dead alive
is extremely gory and exceedingly good
fun thanks to peter jackson's affection
for the tastelessly sublime
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
one vaquita
[Music]
number eight re-animator
a medical student brings his headless
professor back from the dead with a
special serum starring jeffrey combs
bruce abbott barbara crampton and
directed by stuart gordon critics say
perfectly mixing humor and horror the
only thing more effective than
reanimator's gory scares are its dry
deadpan jokes
[Music]
herbert
you hear that sound
west
west
west what is that
[Music]
oh
okay
[Applause]
number seven
wreck
a reporter and her cameraman record the
horrifying outbreak of a disease that
turns humans into vicious cannibals
starring manuela velasco pablo russo
martha carbonell and directed by huame
balaguero and paco plaza critics say
plunging viewers into the nightmarish
hellscape of an apartment complex under
siege rec proves that found footage can
still be used as an effective delivery
mechanism for sparse economic horror
is
[Music]
number six 28 days later
a group of misguided animal rights
activists free a caged chimp infected
with the rage virus from a medical
research lab when london bike courier
jim wakes up from a coma a month after
he finds his city all but deserted on
the run from the zombie-like victims of
the rage jim stumbles upon a group of
survivors including selena and cab
driver frank and joins them on a
perilous journey to what he hopes will
be safety starring killian murphy naomi
harris brendan gleason and directed by
danny boyle critics say kinetically
directed by danny boyle 28 days later is
both a terrifying zombie movie and a
sharp political allegory
[Music]
[Music]
he's clear
it's mr bridges were you bitten
i started they live four doors now well
you were bitten
oh
did any of the blood get in your mouth
mark
number five zombieland
after a virus turns most people into
zombies the world's surviving humans
remain locked in an ongoing battle
against the hungry undead for survivors
tallahassee and his cohorts columbus
wichita and little rock abide by a list
of survival rules and zombie killing
strategies as they make their way toward
a rumored safe haven in los angeles
starring woody harrelson jesse eisenberg
emma stone and directed by ruben
fleischer critics say wickedly funny and
featuring plenty of gore zombieland is
proof that the zombie sub-genre is far
from
[Music]
come
dead
don't get a piece of tallahassee anybody
hungry
gallahash is nice this time of year
[Music]
come on
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
number four knight of the living dead
a disparate group of individuals takes
refuge in an abandoned house when
corpses begin to leave the graveyard in
search of fresh human bodies to devour
the pragmatic ben does his best to
control the situation but when the
reanimated bodies surround the house the
other survivors begin to panic as any
semblance of order within the group
begins to dissipate the zombies start to
find ways inside and one by one the
living humans become the prey of the
deceased ones starring judith o'daya
russell shriner dwayne jones and
directed by george a romero critics say
george a romero's debut set the template
for the zombie film and features tight
editing realistic gore and a sly
political undercurrent
you're ready upstairs
okay toss
[Music]
go ahead go on
[Music]
[Music]
number three train to busan
a man his estranged daughter and other
passengers become trapped on a speeding
train during a zombie outbreak in south
korea starring gong yoo jungyumi kimsu
on and directed by yeon seng ho critics
say train to busan delivers a
thrillingly unique and purely
entertaining take on the zombie genre
with fully realized characters and
plenty of social commentary to
underscore the bursts of skillfully
staged action
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
number two sean of the dead
sean is a 30-something loser with a dull
easy existence when he's not working at
the electronics store he lives with his
slovenly best friend ed in a small flat
on the outskirts of london the only
unpredictable element in his life is his
girlfriend liz who wishes desperately
for sean to grow up and be a man when
the town is inexplicably overrun with
zombies sean must rise to the occasion
and protect both liz and his mother
starring simon pegg kate ashfield nick
frost and directed by edgar wright
critics say shaun of the dead cleverly
balances scares and witty satire making
for a bloody good zombie movie with
loads of wit we'll have to get more
stuff that's in the shed i don't know
it's locked why is it locked it's always
been locked oh
i don't know that's the second half i've
ever bought
now some of these are limited
what was that
[Music]
dinosaurs throw it
oh stone roses uh no
saying coming i like it
ah
chardonnay that's liz's yeah but she did
don't you
there's some gun in the shed he said it
was locked
uh the first one
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
zack snyder's dawn of the dead
when her husband is attacked by a
zombified neighbor anna manages to
escape only to realize her entire
milwaukee neighborhood has been overrun
by the walking dead now after being
questioned by cautious policeman kenneth
anna joins him and a small group that
gravitates to the local shopping mall as
a bastion of safety now once they
convince suspicious security guards that
they are not contaminated the group
bands together to fight the undead
hordes starring sarah paulie ving rhames
jake weber and directed by zack snyder
critics say a kinetic violent and
surprisingly worthy remake of george
romero's horror classic that pays homage
to the original while working on its own
terms
get back anna
get back jesus just tell me what's going
on
i told you to get back
[Applause]
[Music]
emergency broadcast pure milwaukee area
information from milwaukee information
day of the dead
the living dead regroup above while
humans sweat it out below in a florida
missile silo starring lori cardill terry
alexander joseph pilato and directed by
george a romero critics say day of the
dead may arguably be the least haunting
entry in george a romero's undead
trilogy but it will give audiences
plenty to chew on with its shocking gore
and scathing view of society
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
one cut of the dead real zombies attack
a hack director and a film crew who are
shooting a low-budget zombie film in an
abandoned world war ii japanese facility
starring takayuki hamatsu mao harumi
shuhama and directed by shinichiro yuda
critics say brainy and bloody in equal
measure one cut of the dead re-animates
the mori bun zombie genre with a
refreshing blend of formal daring and
clever satire
[Music]
[Music]
funny guys
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
and finally number one dawn of the dead
as hordes of zombies sworn over the
united states the terrified populist
tries everything in their power to
escape the attack of the undead but
neither cities nor the country's side
prove safe in pennsylvania radio station
employees steven and his girlfriend
francine escape in the station
helicopter accompanied by two renegades
swat members roger and pete the group
retreats to the haven of an enclosed
shopping center to make what could be
humanity's last stand starring david m
ghee ken fourie galen ross and directed
by george a romero critics say one of
the most compelling and entertaining
zombie films ever dawn of the dead
perfectly blends pure horror and gore
with social commentary on material
society
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
what is it
steven
you're coming up
[Music]
and friends that about does it for us be
sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and for
even more news scores and
recommendations on the latest tv shows
and movies head on over to
rottentomatoes.com until next time i am
your host naz perez and we'll see you
back here for more top 10s on the rotten
tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you